eia não vamos ser os dois
vamos hoje ajudam também a saúde pessoal
aqui quem falar que sejam muito bem
vindos
a mais curiosa e o cabelo de curva é e
volta à equipe até porque eu com muito
som macho tem coisas para fazer hoje é
preciso contar isso hoje vai acontecer
muita coisa hoje estou muito feliz estou
muito ansioso como muito bem nervoso até
porque o pessoal porque e hoje eu hoje
te roubando na casa dos titulares sabem
que isso aqui é uma passaporte está aqui
serve para viajar entre outros países do
país para mim é hoje hoje precisamente
hoje eu vou viajar
aí pro brasil eu sei que muitos de vocês
entraram pelo título e pela também é o
nep tipo ficaram os estados mas porque
cuidar vai ser caso do youtube porque
porque é eu coloquei esse tipo mesmo
propósito porque hoje eu vou fazer uma
prática o pessoal aqui da casa mas já me
explique melhor javascript agora vou ter
que falar baixo que podemos não saber
que eu vou viajar hoje mas é e onde é
que eu estarei no brasil o pessoal estar
no rock in rio e no rio de janeiro que
vai ser muito louco porque eu nunca vi
gente fora da europa eu acho que o avião
vai demorar um tempo mais 98 horas de
espera e o brasil então é muito tempo e
eu tenho um pouco de medo disso porque
por é porque votar 9 horas tem wi fi sem
internet e isso não pode ser só mas vai
ser muito bom mesmo vai ser bem
divertido portanto vocês podem vir todos
no rock no rio e essa é uma das coisas
que eu também tô muito nervoso e ansioso
porque nunca tive com vocês aí fãs do
brasil e nunca fui ao brasil o que eu
sei que eu vou estar lá no rock in rio
no palco do digital que foi montado
junto de que gosto do brasileiro e eu
vou estar lá a intenção eu não sou o
único carioca windsor também vai
portanto vai ser comigo vai ser o meu
cúmplice que nesta praia
eu acho que cabe ao mp acho que o
ronaldo fazer agora as malas vocês vão
ver tudo ainda vou continuar aqui o blog
quando estiver tudo pronto para ir
embora de malas nas costas vou chamar o
pessoal aqui é o quarto um por um e vou
dizer que vocês da casa tipo
definitivamente vamos ver a criação deus
eu tenho aqui a culpa mas realmente
pronta aqui texto muito de roupa eu
tenho que me comportar humildes que
esperam que os estúdios do canal aqui
tenha deputadores cartões nos fones
perita vídeo aqui bateria do portátil é
bem grande receba crime
sim o meu chinelo também olha aí já não
caiu tudo já não e vulvar também aqui me
go próprio solo comprei um gol para 15
com este torcedor que é muito bom eu não
sei nem como é que eu vou dirigir o meu
tempo e imagem intenção de fazer log
estar logo aí e vamos só agora a fazer a
mala ok
a primeira coisa essencial e roupa muita
roupa lei é muita cueca
obviamente que nunca pode faltar o
chinelo olha aí de chinelo outra coisa
muito importante é um parente uma
bolsinha com toda a higiene e
indicamento inclusive eu voltei como
pentear agora na época eu já arrumei
tudo aqui porque já ruim e muitos fãs
perguntam como é que foi o cabelo em pé
e como vocês podem ver eu não concordo
com ela em plena o tipo tempo gel ou
cera ou seja das coisas o que vamos usar
esta parte aqui do estudo online e ela é
muito boa porque ela tem mesmo tudo pega
se um pouquinho desta página
olha aí podia só vantagem olha só que o
meu filho
depois é só vocês darem um jeito em
poças querem nunca viam e fica pronto
vocês podem usar também é será que
porque é muito bom também mas claro só
se não estarem disponíveis outras coisas
porque isso aqui pois é só o xilindró
sua mochila assim eu já tenho uma conta
que o banco público não gostasse de
textura de cera e sim vocês também podem
usar um gel que os jogos tudo online
está bom em sua textura eu fui sempre
muito pois significa assim fica bem
bonito né coisinhas de beleza dentro da
mala
falta também um chinelo que não pode
faltar né aí eu acho normal está tudo a
foto bonetti boneca eu vou quebrar esse
boné preto e vou usar hormônios viajou
ontem construir 50 informática pelo ok
pessoal eu acho que vou para quito nesta
mala e agora na mala que voltar as
costas voar este eletrônicos todos e não
pessoal eu acho que já está tudo pronto
já tenha 15 malas feitas e eu tenho que
falar baixo os 15 que eu tenho que falar
baixo para o pessoal tá tudo a dormir
nem eu quero que os milhões são ok vamos
lá então que um checklist mauro planta
pronta as coisas podiam prontas tão
lindo alguns carregadores algumas
baterias que têm por na mauá e pronto
agora a única coisa que eu posso fazer é
esperar todos acordam e por chamar um
por um quiprocó eu acho que vai ser
muito louca criação deus eu só queria
esconder este mesmo tempo esconder o
passaporte é preciso vir o passaporte já
sabe que eu vou viajar se bem que eu
posso dizer que fosse da casa por outro
país e após dizer isso eu até posso usar
o passaporte como uma desculpa para
dizer que vou para outro país porque eu
não tenho passaporte então se eu disser
que fui fazer o passaporte de propósito
para sair de casa eu acho que isso torna
as coisas ainda
as reais então é isso quando acordarem
um vôo solo daqui casa já cuidou todo e
eu tenho que me dou comigo a inem
ok já escolhi a câmera também e agora
nós vamos regular financeiro da casa e
eu bata bem triste eu também e vamos ver
a reação do software não ficava em três
são em primeiro com ronaldo como assim
em tokyo no brasil
acho que escolhi da cama e espero que
não vejo meu não é escolhida só poderão
ser lenta
assim o pneu estourado uma coisa à outra
coisa
2 no caso
o domingo de manhã o obrigou a abandonar
kyoto o pneu eo barulho votar num
ambicioso é meu irmão vamos para o
brasil o rio dos sinos em tui os mesmos
carros hoje é a volta então é muito
sério não é que quando quando inicia um
assunto sério eu estava cansado chuvosa
em ninguém só continuará dando a gente
entende que algum caso complica no solo
próximo vamos chamar a upe e agora estou
ensinando o que vai ser a casa não tem
uma noção alguma coisa serei eu já
conheço há muito tempo
se fosse acontecer agora é você casa vai
chorar porque vai ficar com saudade
o futebol escolheu o tributo eu fiz isso
ronaldo se no meu ano já falando em
valores do psol
o brasil deu muita pena que só agora
vamos fazer uma loucura um cérebro não
tem graça o treinador cercada de ajudar
e eu não vou estar agarrada tipo nunca
fazia assim a gente está aqui eu falei
não eu já vou poder conter uma bomba por
tasman a 54 das coisas todas é simples o
dia 15
também não vamos ter essa postura se a
prefeitura contava tanto e nós voltamos
a gente quer o nosso espaço de um ano
enquanto não sabemos a gente vai vai a
descoberta de uma faca tipo e etapa
jackman vai fazer vir já
eu não só vou à casa do jovem thiago
neves jogou o aeroporto escolha uma
viagem qualquer à noite
mãe justiça como é que nós vamos
escolher nem poderia imaginar que
realmente tenha já atua acho que a
nasdaq omx queimando triste estou
podendo porto conseguir fazer isso mas
eu não vou conseguir acompanhar eu
estava um pouco mas eu já fiz que age
como um pato deixou eu falei bem no
centro tem que acabar depois nas costas
em uma trama eu também tenho as minhas
coisas e eu quero ter uma vida fora
destaque celeste já 95 pontos hoje
mantém um banco e tem culpa eu posso
grosso tem que fazer o que o sr
como é que eu vou embora
se o brasil dos maia e agora é o nono
não não interessa a eles eu sempre falei
que a prova está aqui é incrível de sair
caso não sei como vou novamente e eu
quero comprar uma passagem à torre só
vamos agora é que estão aqui contamos
chamar 11
quero informar isso e por quê
[Música]
eu já não posso ir a uma semana quando
não todo são 50 que eu queria uma casa
queria entrar aquele tipo viral a trip
assim que ontem não se não fosse o
primeiro a mesma coisa consigo
compreender isso é lógico obter razão
impacto chega aquele salão vai usar pois
pois foi bruninho assim algo assim o
ator 14 que contigo nós vemos todos
respeitoso com força agora na rua da
noite
gum dalton e explorar e muito peixe no
brasil todo o serviço é meu irmão de
zico
hoje só o próximo ano mesmo sério
assim o tse já não tá muito cheio aqui
em casa já não já não possuir uma semana
ruim do médio de quatro em quatro dias
que já não tão difícil aqui vamos ganhar
uma viagem estou indo ao banco mas já
sei qual é a tua opinião certeza isso é
mesmo assim mandam ficha que a mulher em
questão não eu não te está tão difícil
falar em herança de homicídio de seu
filho com você já o físico sílvio 2
antes as pessoas é mais por aí eu entrei
com isso já é uma cena quando nós
chegamos não fosse pela região já
chegava a ter uma melhor pessoa e
escolhemos uma viagem a nós ou não sei
do país
simples é que a fiscalização deve ser
revisto de última hora do flamengo éa
orla do flamengo
agora nós temos um comportamento
machista que passa você não faz uma
razão ao aeroporto não conseguirmos
poderemos ter a mesma razão da chuva que
atingiu todos os convidados sete
camisetas com a imagem não ficou forte
como esse fiquem com tudo o que ela está
no caminho eu queria ter vindo tanto
quero explorar cenas tempo visitaria em
casa dizendo falar do caso em uma cerca
de dois dias e eu também quero ver meu
caso ela vai sim e com cartoons chegar a
4 em casa
cinco guardas dentro de quadra melhor
falou nada quer fazer vou pra casa
negócio porque só porque você vai pra
casa não é você vai achar soluções mas
não que tem dá mais fácil eu faço os
vossos filhos da mesma
acho que ela não fique chateado nato é
triste né num tubo todo não estava à
espera mas aqui está é só espero que
passe por favor deixem os que estão aqui
ficaram tipo não quer um quer usar de
maneira assim mandou mano
nós estamos focando consiste em um
pacote com as coisas todas de manutenção
têm portagem mesmo tocado pelo andaló
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esse álbum dos pobrezinhos pan am
hoje embora o interesse pessoal do caso
não está em causa agora deve ter saído
para ir a um farol assim eu não sei se
vai dar tempo pra nós fazemos a reação
deu mas é isso só aquele assunto que só
tocar a bola por cima por cima e faça um
leão e é isso que o cachorro vamos
entrar agora no avião